les arrivées du public sont successives
et les caisses ne sont jamais vraiment
déserté pour ces vacances les équipes de
ce complexe saint quentinois sont
complétés cinq personnes renforce les
rangs sur les vacances de noël on va
faire un peu près 40 40 mille personnes
par semaine donc la voyez on a deux
semaines pleines
voilà le nombre qu'on va faire et on est
partis sur des très beaux succès encore
cette année en termes de films et parmi
les succès des films à voir en famille
le dernier disney bien sûr vaiana la
légende du bout du monde totalise déjà
près de 2 millions d'entrées en france
et rend gwan
le spin off de la saga star wars vivez
pleinement ce moment là force est
puissante
tous ces films la belle sortait un petit
peu en même temps il se télescopent bon
cette année ça va à peu près il ya aussi
bas lerida par exemple un film
d'animation qui fonctionne très bien
donc
donc il ya de quoi faire gabo l'offre et
dans cette salle élan courtois ce sont
jusqu'à quinze mille entrées au mois de
décembre avec des animations
supplémentaires
un moyen aussi de faire découvrir aux
plus jeunes les dessins animés de notre
enfance
plusieurs séances nostalgie sont prévues
vous lasser
sous le ca d'où vous est bien mieux tout
le monde est heureux sous l'océan